this is the Jocko underground podcast
number 61 sitting here with Echo Charles
and the last one we talked about how
your name or the name you give people or
the nickname you give people or the name
you give a team might impact the way
that they act and what they do in their
life similar thing here the Pygmalion
effect this is a psychological
phenomenon where high expectations of
someone
led to their improved performance
conversely low expectations lead to
worse performance this is from something
called
academy4sc.org it's an educational
website this is where I
took this information stole this
information stole these quotes from but
that's who it is so I'm citing them
citing their reference so we can talk
about the name Pygmalion refers to a
Greek myth about a talented sculptor as
The Story Goes Pygmalion fell in love
with one of his Creations an ivory
statue of a woman thanks to some divine
intervention the statue came to life and
he later married her his expectations
became as reality so that's the key
point there expectations become reality
the Pygmalion effect was first noted by
psychologist Robert Rosenthal and
Elementary School principal principal
Lenore Jacobson in a 1965 study called
Pygmalion in the classroom researchers
told teachers that a select group of
their Elementary School students had a
high potential for exceeding their
expected academic success success based
on an intelligence test
however the results of the intelligence
test were not disclosed to the teachers
and the growth spurters as they were
called were selected at random
Rosenthal and Jacobson predicted that
teachers might subconsciously favor the
students who were expected to
overachieve perhaps by paying closer
attention to their work or offering more
help when they struggled with an
assignment the study found that the
randomly selected growth spurders did in
fact perform better than other students
despite there being no statistical
difference in their intelligence scores
so there you go straight up
yeah it's another indication of how and
this is something that's just been
shocking me for the last few years how
pliable people's minds are
just how people can be so easily
influenced by what's happening around
them and in this case the teachers are
getting influenced by what they're told
who's smart and the students are being
influenced by them being told by the
teachers it's just a one big lie
the pygmalia effect is a kind of
self-fulfilling prophecy again this is
back to academy4sc.org
self-fulfilling prophecy is when a
person expects or predicts an outcome
and subconsciously aligns their
behaviors to meet that expected outcome
simply because they believe that it has
to come true
the teachers in the Pygmalion in the
classroom study believe that certain
students would perform better and
inadvertently willed this outcome into
existence with their teaching strategies
the pygmaline effect also works in the
reverse direction if teachers were told
that a cohort of students would
underperform they likely would have
subconsciously devoted less attention to
these students
causing these students
achievement to decrease
such a and it seems real obvious right
doesn't seem obvious
especially with kids yeah but it's just
across the board and yet even though
it's obvious think about how think about
how sometimes you're in a leadership
position or you see someone in a
leadership position and you see how
they're treating people and you know
it's going to have a negative effect
you just know it's gonna have a negative
effect and yet you still see that taking
place
uh
so
treating people in a way that you
anticipate their good performance having
a positive attitude about something how
hard is that foreign
have you ever tricked yourself with like
a positive attitude yes they they they
had something in buds basic SEAL
training they'd say false motivation is
better than no motivation
and it was kind of a joke and sometimes
they'd be like oh I can tell this is
false motivation you're gonna break like
they would say that kind of stuff but
you know what's true false motivation is
better than no motivation yeah 100 is
yeah and you could hear like one person
would start acting fired up just acting
literally yeah and then that would kind
of go through yeah and I'd probably do
that all the time yeah you know yeah I
don't really feel like doing this but
you know what watch this yeah I want to
do it that's what I was doing a football
when I was in uh Pop Warner football
what would you do just yell like so so I
played for the claw Rams and the color
Raiders absolutely two different ages
right or age groups so color Rams they
our coach had a policy that we would
when we do our grass drills and our
yields we drills we had to yell just to
I guess it would get us fired up or
whatever when we went up to the next
level we didn't have to do that I mean
good for him since the dawn of War right
has been a yell a scream like an assault
or an attack we're gonna like so yeah I
think that was a really good move
because that's peewee's is the younger
guys it's like nine to eleven yeah
everything yeah you have to yell
otherwise you're not doing it right and
then and also he had us in uniform like
we all had to wear long white so it was
like he had us in uniform more than the
other teams too so I think that that was
a goodness dude was squared away
I think so so anyway
um so we got trained into that so I was
I was down to do it and I saw like yeah
it does help you it gives you energy to
do you know like when you're going
through J you're kind of tired but if
you have to yell it like actually gives
you energy some false energy better than
no energy right so uh we went up to
midgets they didn't require all that but
every time that I never didn't feel like
doing it or whatever like I I just like
do that like yeah because some people
would still yell I don't know it's like
pop warner so whatever you just yell so
when I would do that or there's this one
it's basically like the football version
of sprawls right yeah but you hit your
chest on them on the ground and get back
up and run yes and then I'd hit the
ground as hard like hard like a hard
impact you know which is kind of the
same effect right I just do that but it
was it was good just because I didn't
feel like it but when you did it it
would like kind of make you fire dump
and give you a lot of energy
there you go yeah yeah so
that kind of energy yes for an
individual you can use that but also as
a leader as a parent as a mom or a dad
giving that kid treating that kid truly
treating that kid like they're special
in this certain way which is you know
everyone's like oh everyone's special
now no we're not talking about that yeah
but saying hey you could do awesome in
this
there's I've also the little contrary to
this is
have you ever heard that
um advice which I've actually given
before you don't I don't like you do
good your your 10 years old you do good
in a jiu jitsu tournament
I don't say
I shouldn't say oh Echo you're so
talented what I should say is hey your
hard work really paid off you practiced
hard and it really came through you're
so focused it's so that there's a
difference here right so this is not to
say oh Echo you're so talented you just
have a natural gift for this because
then you're gonna try and ride that or
there's a possibility and I rewarded
that I I praised your talent right which
is something you don't actually have any
control over you have control over how
hard you work so if I'm praising your
hard work I'm praising your focus so
that's something to be careful of here
you know we're not saying just go out
and false cheerlead your kids and be
like hey you're staying down didn't get
then you're so special I'm not saying
that say Hey your hard work is going to
pay off oh the way that you push
yourself that's legit yeah you ever done
that with a little kid yes like hey the
way you push yourself is weird that's
that's what I'm talking about yeah
very fun to watch that take effect too
yeah
do you that's what we got to do all
right well so there you go let's
set that up right in life man set your
team upright set your kids upright every
little thing you say to him that's the
weird thing when you when you go when
you expose a little bit deeper it's
these little subtle things yeah it's
little subtle things like even the way
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen
go to Jocko underground.com And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you just email assistance
Jocko underground.com and we'll get you
taken care of until then we will see you
immobilized
Underground